[Musique]
c'est une des chanteuses les plus
importantes de l'histoire de la musique
la reine du rock n' roll
originaire du Tennessee
qui deviendra-t-il à Turner a commencé
sa carrière aux côtés son premier mari
un homme avec qui est le véhicule un
véritable calvaire une période atroce
qu'elle raconte courageusement dans une
biographie et un biopic qui
contribueront à lever les tabous
entourant la violence conjugale
[Musique]
avec sa grande voix puis maintenant elle
vient automatiquement donner une voix à
des millions de femmes sur la planète
qui ont pas de voix parce que vivre dans
des situations de violence
en solo Tina Turner enchaîne les succès
et les performances époustouflantes
[Musique]
avec sa voix s'y remarquable elle
interprète quelques-unes des chansons de
films les plus marquantes que ce soit
pour Mad Max dans lequel elle joue
également ou encore pour James Bond
durant cinq décennies Tina Turner a su
s'adapter se réinventer et devenir un
symbole de puissance elle a remporté
huit grandes il y a une pièce de théâtre
présentement sur Broadway qui joue basé
sur sa vie et elle a fait un
documentaire dernièrement qui s'appelle
itina et dans ce documentaire elle nous
raconte que ce sera la dernière fois
qu'on va la voir parler à la télévision
sur son compte Instagram sont gérants a
annoncé qu'elle est décédée mardi à
l'âge de 83 ans laissant des millions de
femmes en deuil mais avec des souvenirs
impérissables
cette femme-là quand émettait un pied
sur scène et devenir colossal je pense
qu'il y a plusieurs personnes plusieurs
femmes aussi qui avaient besoin d'avoir
une femme comme ça si grande sur scène à
la télévision partout à travers les
médias
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'une des meilleures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]